in the last video we started off with
two linear transformations we had the
linear transformation s that was a
mapping from rn
to rm
and then we had the linear
transformation t
that was also a mapping from rn
to
r
m
and we defined the idea of the addition
of two
of these two transformations so s plus t
this
transformation of x we defined as being
equal to
s of
x
this vector plus
plus t
plus t of x and of course this will be
in our this input is still from rn and
then this each of these are vectors in
rm if we add two vectors to r in rm to
each other we get another vector in rm
because rm is a valid subspace it's also
closed under addition so this is still a
mapping so s plus t
s plus t is still a mapping from rn
to
r
m
and we also said that look every linear
transformation we've shown in a previous
video can be represented as a matrix
that we could say that s
of x is equal to some matrix a times x
and we could also say that t
of x
is equal to some matrix b times x and
these both of these would be m by n
matrices they'd and let me write that m
by n both of these because these are
both mappings from rn to rm
and what we did is we made another
definition
we defined this was a definition right
here
then we made another definition
we defined the addition of two matrices
we said the matrix a
this is any matrix a plus b they both
have to have the same dimensions
same
dimensions so they're both m by n in
this case and we defined
this addition
to be a new matrix
where each column of this matrix is the
sum of the corresponding columns of
these matrices so this matrix matrices
this matrix's first column will be the
sum of a's first column in b's first
column so a1
plus b1
the second column i'll do a little line
here is a2
plus b2
and it goes all the way
to a n
plus
b n
this was a definition and the whole
reason why we made this definition is
because if you defined matrix addition
in this way then this thing
this thing
when you replace it with ax plus bx you
get to
that this thing over here is equal to it
the corresponding matrices by this
definition
a plus b
times x that was this was the motivation
this was the motivation
to get to a nice expression like this
for defining matrix addition in this way
now this this all seems very abstract so
let's actually add a matrix
or let's add two matrices so we'll start
off with a two by two case
so let's say i'm adding the matrix one
three minus two four
to the matrix remember they have to have
the same dimensions
to the matrix two
minus 3
minus 1 what do we get
well by definition you just add up their
corresponding columns you add up the
first column when you add up the
corresponding columns what happens when
you add up two columns two two vectors
well you just add up their corresponding
entries so essentially when you add up
two matrices you're just adding up all
of the corresponding entries i'll talk
about it in this way just because that's
how i defined it but it's they're all
equivalent so let's we're the first
thing the first column in this matrix
right here is going to be this column
plus this column so it's going to be one
plus two let me write it like this one
plus two and then minus two minus three
minus two minus three
and then the second
column that one right there
is going to be three plus seven
three plus seven and then four minus one
four minus one and so this will be equal
to
three
ten
minus 5
and
3 just like that and notice even though
the definition is i'm adding up
corresponding columns but what in effect
happened well i'm just adding up the
corresponding entries i added the 1 to
the two the three to the seven the minus
two to the minus three the four to the
minus one it's that straightforward
nothing fancier than that in fact we
could have we could have rewritten this
definition
we could rewritten this definition if we
if we say that the vector or the matrix
a is equal to
you know a 1 1
a 1 2 all the way to a 1 n and then if
you go down this is a 2 1 all the way to
a n 1 and you go all the way down there
to a n n
we've seen that before and then the
matrix b
just by the same argument or by you know
similar definition is this b 1 1 that
entries b 1 1 that's b 1 2 all the way
to b1n this is b21 second row all the
way down to b
n oh sorry this is m
we have m rows so this is m n
so this right here is b
m 1 this would be b m 2 all the way down
to this is b
m
n
right there i want to be very careful
these are m by n matrix matrices so this
this row down here is the nth row in
both cases but we could redefine our
matrix or another way of stating this
matrix addition definition is to say
look if i'm going to add a plus b
i'm going to add a plus b i'm just going
to add up the corresponding entries so
this entry up here is going to be doing
a different color
it's going to be a11 plus b11 this one's
going to be a 2 1 plus b 2 1 all the way
down to a
m 1 plus b m 1
and then this is going to be of course a
1 2 plus b 1 2 all the way to a 1 n
let me scroll over a little bit all the
way over to a 1n plus b
1n and then all the way down to
a
m n plus b m n these are equivalent
definitions this just this takes a lot
less space to write in i felt
comfortable doing it because we've
already defined matr vector addition but
it essentially boils down to you just
add up all of the corresponding entries
that's all matrix edition is it's it's
probably one of the simplest things that
you've seen in in your recent
mathematical experience now matrix
scalar multiplication very similar idea
we defined
we defined scalar multiplication times a
transformation
of x to be equal to
a scalar times the transformation of x
this was a definition
this was a definition and we also
defined
we also defined
scalar times some matrix a to be equal
to the scalar
a new matrix where each of its columns
are the scalar times the column vectors
of a so a1
and then the next column is ca2
and then you go all the way to c
c
a n
and the whole motivation for this was
because this could be simplified to
well t i've said was equal to b x the
transformation sorry this is a times the
transformation of x the transformation t
of x was equal to
so this we still have our c so it's
going to be c times
the matrix b
times the vector x that's what the
transformation of x could be written as
and so this would be equal to
and so if i use my this would be equal
to
by just manipulating and we did this in
the last video by actually breaking this
up in the column vectors multiplying
them by each of the components of x and
then distributing the c and rearranging
a little bit we can now say using this
definition that this is equal to
some new matrix cb
we're using this definition
some new matrix cb where it's
essentially c times each of the column
vectors of b
times x
this right here was our motivation we
wanted to be able to express this as a
product of a some new matrix
and a vector because any linear
transformation should be expressible in
that way and that's why we made this
definition now let's apply it and i i
wanted to show you that this is this is
perhaps even simpler than matrix
addition so if we want to multiply the
scalar 5 times the matrix i'll do a 3 by
2 matrix so 1 minus 1 2 3
this will just be equal to
by this definition i'm just saying look
i'm multiplying the scalar times each of
the column vectors so it's 5 times 1 2
7. but what's that that's just 5 times
each of the entries so it's 5 times 1
which is 5 5 times 2 which is 10
5 times 7 which is 35 then the next
column is going to be 5 times this
column right here which is just 5 times
each of its entries so 5 times minus 1
is minus 5. 5 times 3 is 15 5 times 0 is
0. it's that simple you literally if we
go back to this definition
we can define
scalar multiplication of a matrix so we
could also define ca as being equal to
if we say this is a representation for a
of the scalar c times each of the
entries of a that's it so it's c
times a 1 1 c times a 1 2 all the way to
c times a 1 n you go down this way
c times a 2 1 all the way down to c
times a m
1 and then if you go down the diagonal
it's b c times a
m n you literally just take your scalar
and multiply it times every entry in a
and that's all you have to do so
hopefully this clarified things up a
little bit or maybe it was a bit of
review from things you might have
learned in high school